i
[Música]
ah
américa latina' presenta a un alarmante
declive en biodiversidad esa es la
advertencia de la asociación fondo
mundial para la naturaleza entre 1970 y
2016 en américa latina' la reducción de
la biodiversidad alcanzó el 94 por
ciento entre sus causas el cambio de uso
del suelo para producir alimentos como
por ejemplo la conversión de bosques
praderas o manglares en sistemas
agrícolas además de la sobrepesca en
océanos es precisamente en estos
entornos donde viven el 90% de los
organismos vivos desde la asociación
inciden en la importancia de la
biodiversidad ya que es la que garantiza
los recursos necesarios para vivir así
como la seguridad alimentaria o la lucha
contra las pandemias una preocupación no
sólo para la región sino para el mundo
ya que el 60 por ciento de la vida
terrestre mundial se encuentra en
américa latina' siendo el amazonas' la
región que alberga el 10 por ciento de
la biodiversidad mundial mientras en los
últimos 50 años se han arrasado con el
15 por ciento de su superficie
[Música]
el más reciente informe el fondo mundial
para la naturaleza wwf ha revelado unas
impactantes cifras el informe dice que
en los últimos 50 años se ha reducido en
dos terceras partes la biodiversidad
mundial y me aplica en particular esta
cifra es del 65 por ciento según el
informe y así como el sobreconsumo la
actividad humana y como consecuencia el
cambio climático son factores que
afectan a todo el mundo
áfrica tiene sus propios desafíos aquí
por ejemplo se lleva a cabo la tala
indiscriminada de bosques en áreas como
la del congo y en guinea bissau por
nombrar solamente dos países que afectan
tanto la flora como la fauna en una de
las zonas más biodiversas del mundo
también en los últimos años en áfrica y
sobre todo en el sur y en el este se ha
disparado la caza furtiva de
rinocerontes y de elefantes y esto se
debe a que sus cuernos tienen un alto
valor en el mercado negro en el sudeste
asiático donde se estima o donde se cree
que estos elementos tienen propiedades
medicinales la pesca indiscriminada
también en ocasiones llevada a cabo por
compañías occidentales y con métodos no
permitidos que dañan el suelo marino se
llevó a cabo tanto en el cuerno de
áfrica como en el golfo de guinea y por
mencionar sólo algunas de las especies
que están en peligro podemos hablar
tanto el gorila de los gorilas en él
y en ruanda y así como del oro gris en
gana los expertos de la w w han
expresado también que si el ritmo de
explotación de la biodiversidad continúa
de esta manera se presentan más
posibilidades de que los surgen
enfermedades como el ébola o como el
mismo kobe 19
[Música]
según el informe del fondo mundial para
la naturaleza entre 1970 y 2016 la
región asia-pacífico perdió el 45 por
ciento de su población de vertebrados de
acuerdo al reporte las causas fueron el
cambio en el uso del suelo la
sobreexplotación de especies y también
la contaminación la situación más grave
se vive en india que perdió el 12 por
ciento de sus mamíferos salvajes el 19
por ciento de sus anfibios y el 3 por
ciento de sus aves sin embargo desde
2010 la región asia-pacífico ha venido
mostrando signos de recuperación con el
aumento en algunas especies de reptiles
y anfibios el fondo mundial para la
naturaleza les ha hecho un llamado a los
países de la región para que promuevan
leyes y políticas públicas que protejan
los entornos y también a las especies
pues algunas en un futuro próximo
podrían estar en riesgo de extinción
[Música]